there's a benefit to being in a city
where you're a kid or an adult there's
definitely a benefit the negative part
is that this depreciation of value of
life people there's so many people you
don't think of them as being as
important they're they're a hindrance as
much as they are like a nice thing to
see yeah well there's so many homeless
people - mm-hmm and there's a homeless
woman who basically stands on my corner
and just begs for change every day and
my son was with me the other day
and this woman she's like hey do you
have any money for a sandwich and I was
like no sorry I don't today and I keep
on walking and then my out with down my
son he's like Ted that's really sad she
doesn't have money for a sandwich and
I'm like she has every fucking day James
everyday yes okay and I'd explained to
him I was like I was like well you know
look I can't give her money every single
day and it's like you know what I do
have a dollar though I was like why
don't we go back and give her a dollar
and it was like no I get it now I swear
to god he stopped me from giving her the
dollar well if the world was just one if
there was only one person like that and
that was the only issue just one lady
just need some help you'd be uh we'll
just help her yeah but when there's a
million of them you know like I can't
help I just can't do this I got to keep
going
I got to concentrate on my own shit yeah
that's like that's a microcosm of what
happens in a city if that lady was in a
small town she would be the the crazy
beggar lady people would probably like
figure out a way to help her cans
yeah some people the problem is is just
like humans some humans when you give
them that as an option just begging like
there's guys who do it and there was a
whole sanford when I lived in San
Francisco there was a news report thing
about this guy was doing it for a living
he was making a lot of money a lot of
money now he's just begging and he was
essentially saying there's nothing wrong
with it it's totally legal and I just
make up stories and have people donate
money to me and I think of it as like an
occupation so he it was weird listening
to him talk about it because he was
telling this lady who was the reporter
lady was telling her how she could do it
too and you know how he was doing it
shows people how to do it but he was
making like a decent living couple
hundred bucks a day yeah I'm sure I
remember cuz I was a kid but I remember
listen like oh this motherfucker he's
just faking it
I don't in a weird way I I appreciate
the hustle I don't look i watch my mom
on well if i remember as a kid watching
my mom collect a welfare check and
sitting in the room smoke cigarettes and
not work and i remember as a little kid
being like that's not right I was like
what are you doing just work do
something else we could be in a better
situation just from way too young having
that thought right but in a weird way I
I appreciate the guys hustle he's
figured out a way to thrive sorta it's
not nothing to be proud of you know he
shouldn't be bragging about it but at
the same time like it's just a different
system it's a different game we if you
disconnect from sort of like you know
whatever we're you know he's a con
artist there's not never a good thing
having someone who's lying to everybody
all the time
I appreciate you con artists I really do
they're boring yeah yeah it's boring
it's boring just figure it out stupid
stop lying aren't they figured something
different they're just finding lemmings
that's all they're doing they're finding
lemmings they're finding people that
don't know any better people that what's
three-card Monte come on I'll show you
well that's all the homeless lady is
doing she there's Nell look I've been in
New York City since 2001 I've sewed a--
sensitized to homeless people that i
there's no part of me that feels bad I
just will walk on sorry I can't keep on
going but what happens is you get there
they're looking for the person who moved
there a week ago they're looking for the
tourists they're looking for the person
who's looking for nice people and
they're they're there so it's sort of
like that's but that's not the same
thing like that lady might just be crazy
she's not a con artist con artists are
people lying and pretending they listen
my car broke down my wife and kid
haven't had anything to eat in 24 hours
and I'm really in a bad situation I
would never do this but I just asked you
if you could just give me five dollars
and the guy says oh that yeah I meant
sure I'm sorry here's $5 next person hey
man I need to go take this flight to see
my mom she's dying of cancer little
change usually they have less old and
they'll change all the time well I had a
guy do that to me in New York when I
first moved there and now the guy he was
wearing a suit young white guy wearing a
suit he's like did I miss my bus back
home was here for a job interview
I'm just trying to get money for a bus
ticket back home and also guys here's a
couple bucks whatever and the next day
and Union Square same fucking kids same
suit same story because they learn it
like a sales pitch so they know the
beats up they know exactly what to say
you see it went on the subway when they
get on the subway they have an actual
script you know so it's like you know I
don't mean to beg you know but my wife
is blah blah blah and you see them every
day going down the cart and it if you
ever done a sales job a good sales
script is pretty good you're just sort
of fishing you're playing the numbers
you're you're instead of sort of adding
a motion to it and changing the story
and doing all these different things and
putting too much thought into it you go
I'm gonna run the script and close one
out of 20 people that walk by stupid ya
know it's not only benefit is that you
grow up around people that are full of
shit and you learn how to spot people
that are full of shit so much benefit I
mean that's just annoying I agree with
you but I also can't appreciate it I can
I can appreciate a good hustler I
appreciate goes out gets a fucking job
you don't just lie to people everywhere
with some stupid story about how you
missed your bus shit together pussy stop
mooching money from people that's gross
well what about it's gross what about a
guy who sells his CD on the street
that's maybe a bit different because
he's offering something he has his art
nobody had a CD player you do have a CD
player I do don't want up top I got a
refurbished laptop this guy in Columbus
you're sort of reminding me I completely
forgot about him he was known as the
rapping bum but or help us on the way
fifteen twenty years at Ohio State
didn't this guy be on the high street
which is like the main strip and he had
this all these rhymes he would
constantly go to it always in it with
help is on the way but I don't remember
a lot of them but he always said help is
on the way and it like it was like his
punchline that help is on the way
he had t-shirts made about him I think
people someone I really recorded him at
one point in like 2005 or 6 but you
remember when they found that homeless
dude that had that crazy radio voice
yeah that was in Columbus too was it
yeah oh yeah he came a jog went right
back to the pipe a fuck today
well you can't can't fix him like that
voice was fire though it's very good
voice
yeah great voice radio voice you got a
lot of smooth
yeah and he just wound up going right
back to being a homeless person well do
that I mean it's not it's gonna sound
very insensitive but most of the time
it's not bad luck right you know it's
sort of the decisions you make and I'm
not saying that you can have a bad
situation and you can't you know there's
bad luck in the sense that some people
are born into you know affluent
households some people are born into
poverty but this is him
you know this him what's he wear a do
guy yeah and then he fell on her well
and don't forget tomorrow morning is
your chance to win a pair of tickets to
see this man live in concert I have a
theory I think doing that for a living
makes you fucking crazy that's what I
think I think if you have that fake
voice eventually you just snap you know
I can't do this anymore I can't talk
like this I can't have this fake voice
yeah blow a few